foreign
you
now
good morning
i think we're uh semi-ready
to
start our work for the day and we have
one hearing this morning
to begin with
and that is house bill
relative to the chartered public school
joint legislative oversight committee
and the prime sponsor is representative
tanner and she is uh ready to go i'm
ready to go
so good morning colleagues for the
record i'm representative linda tanner
sullivan ix
i represent the towns of plainfield
cornish grantham
sunapee
croydon newport
springfield and unity up in the
beautiful sunapee area sunapee lakes
area
isn't it isn't the
switzerland of new hampshire though okay
so this is a bill that i had started
back before we
canceled everything because of covid
and it got lost in those omnibus bills
or didn't get in actually an omnibus
built and it's also a little bit
confusing because i think we
also discussed before about how um
there was movement to get you know every
new session there's a movement to go
through
the different uh committees uh
the
like the oversight committees
and see which ones have been meeting and
which ones haven't and
try to get a handle on which ones to
continue
this one one of the reasons i think it
stayed in was because of this bill that
i had
submitted before to try to address the
the oversight committee because i think
it's very important
charter schools are going to play a role
in our our
public school system have uh they offer
an alternative and i
i
want to say right up front that that i
support types of charter schools
um i think they're important
um
for a lot of different reasons
but the charters and i've passed out
information
charter schools started in 1996
and originally originally their
mission was
to provide a laboratory for innovative
education
and
the original concept was
by the name of the fellow that uh
devised this his idea was for groups of
teachers to set up contracts
or charters with their local school
boards
to discover new approaches and ids in
the field of education and then
bring those back
to see if they could be
used in the in the general public
education system
however over the years
particularly
in the last few years
charter schools have kind of taken
a little bit of a turn
we still have some of those schools
charter schools that are
schools
that are doing quite well that
are
innovative um they're usually centered
around a certain theme
and they do really well um and
all charter schools are trying to do the
best they can uh but it's now it seems
to be more
to offer
an independent
alternative for the public school system
that's independent
from the existing school district or
school system structure
and being exempt from many of the
regulations that public schools are put
on and i just can't say that enough
that public school systems in in the
state of new hampshire are over
regulated and underfunded and we just
seem to be putting more regulations on
them all the time
so
as part of the statute in
your yellow books or whatever color
behind
you'll find that there's a legislative
oversight committee for charter schools
and
when i went back to look at the charter
schools and do a little bit of review on
them
i found out that this particular
legislative oversight committee
was very active in the beginning and if
you look at the second page
you'll see that there's um
there's a
a chart that shows
how often the meetings were held
and even after they weren't being held
which is really kind of interesting
people were still putting in legislation
to change the oversight committee
and there's many reasons that a than an
oversight committee or any committee
like that
and when we were talking about the study
of the study yesterday many reasons why
study committees don't don't meet
oftentimes it's because they can't get a
quorum get people all together
so
what i tried to do is i tried to through
this bill offer some changes that i
thought could revitalize the committee
and also
be a true legislative oversight
committee that actually looks at the at
the program um and not just the
financial or application part of it so
what i have in this is that uh you know
we've got chairs
from the house and senate committee or
their designees so they can isn't you
know right based on those on the
education committee a member from the
finance committee because charter
schools
have a very special type of financing
appoint
people that are appointed by the senate
president and the speaker of the house
and then a non-voting charter school
specialist from the department of
education
and set it up so it actually has
allowance for mileage
meets twice a year
and then expand a little bit the area of
oversight so that
they receive
and review the reports from the state
board of education that's part of the
statute that they
they are supposed to get an annual
report from
the state board
about charter schools
and i don't know if that's happening or
not it's kind of hard to find some of
these things
deliver their report to the education
committees in the house and senate
because i think as we're finding things
we need to
make sure that
people find out about the great things
that charter schools are doing and some
of the issues that charter schools have
that maybe we can help them out
and and try to make this
particular part of the public school
system and public
a little bit
more effective and efficient
monitor the effects of the charter
school statutes so we have a whole
section on charter schools review the
charter school system
and in the early years as i've put here
the charter school system actually had a
review and
it was
quite an involved review
it not only did their financial but it
also did their academic
and mission and
that was done by an outside organization
and then for a number of years there was
no review of charter schools and then
recently within the last i think maybe
five or six years i not quite sure
the department of education has started
that again but as you can imagine they
have a backlog because as we get more
charters and the fact they didn't do
reviews before they're now catching up
uh you know once every five years
they're supposed to review charter
schools and i think it's important to
make that transparent so that those
reviews are available to the to the
public and to the parents of the
students that are going to the charter
school and also to the education
committees who are trying to make
legislation or not um to help this whole
system
and then um
at the end of my remarks i just left a
couple of
places that you may want to just look
the first one is a reference to the
beginning of charter schools
so
that's my little spiel
and i've offered it in house bill 1047
and
i'll take any questions are there any
questions for the presenter yes
represent hobson
um thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question i
apologize for being late um i wanted to
just ask you when was the last time this
committee met do you know um well if you
look at the second page right
uh it goes uh
2018 okay and that was the last that i
had an opportunity to actually
do it but as you can see
um
you know there had been uh
at least 2017 seems to be the last time
and they actually scheduled a meeting
right after i submitted the bill
uh two years ago and i sat outside
waiting for the
meeting to start and never started
so
it wasn't held then either
it was scheduled but not held
further question representative cordelli
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
representative
i just wanted to see what the actual
changes
are
being proposed because this is a repeal
and reenactment of the existing statute
so
looking at it
would i be correct that the
main changes that you are suggesting in
this
bill
are the makeup of the committee
um the date of the committee to submit a
report on line 24. that's a change
and just line 2829 and the
date for the state board
to issue a report if they have any
are those the only changes yeah um i
think i i listed it on my um
my paper that i sent out to you that the
major changes were the makeup of the
committee
um and hopefully with this makeup uh it
will allow uh
you know the current one i think only
has
um three or four members to it so
if one of the senators don't show up and
then somebody else is not available it
just doesn't go and that's the problem
so
making the committee a little bit more
expanded having the non-voting member
from the department of education
specializing in charter schools
the meeting schedule and and the dates
when it's due and also a little bit on
the expanded area of oversight and
reporting those are the three basic
things
uh representative porter
thank you mr chair um
representative
do you know
are there any reports
on charter schools that are available to
the public
on a yearly basis i know my local school
district puts out the yearly report card
that
the does
does on them it's on their website is
there anything like that for charter
schools do you know
um when we did this back two years ago
uh i couldn't find anything at that
point and and really i'm not a expert
researcher uh jen helped me a little bit
on it but um
i couldn't i couldn't find anything
representative i have a question for you
um
in in the past and i'm trying to recall
why you have chosen to go the route of
putting a non-voting member on a
committee which is usually a legislative
assignment
in the legislative oriented committee
verse where we have committees or
councils like advisory councils such as
we have in numerous areas
where in fact we have
some folks from doe chairing those
particular councils or commissions where
we have active involvement
in this case you've gone the other way
and put it on a legislative committee
which are are you aware of that if
that's done like that and any other
committees we have i'm not and i must
say that um
the the uh
gentleman that it that is the principle
of the ledger charter school up in my
area uh also used to be a colleague of
mine and so
when i was developing this i actually
talked to him and uh he was distressed
that you know
as i think teachers and principals and
school board members in general are
distressed that you know they feel as
though the legislative work goes in a
bubble
that doesn't know what's really
happening out in the field and um he
suggested that uh yes have you know have
a legislative oversight committee he was
uh okay with that but he said you need
to have somebody there
that's um
going to be there on a regular basis
that actually knows what's going on in
the charter school field and i so as a
compromise to him
not not a compromise but taking that
suggestion from him
my solution was to come up with
having somebody from the department of
education which i think they probably
would show up just like
attorney fenton shows up here uh for the
meeting and but put it in in the legis
in the um
makeup of the committee
so that they would be invited on a
regular basis and be there as an expert
in the field of charter schools
i understand where you're where you're
going and and the purpose behind that
but i question
whether that we can do that uh every
committee that i know of and would you
believe that every committee that i've
been part of we've always had either
dyna fenton there or we've had jeff
beard there or we've had eric
froworth there you know all these
directors always make sure when we ask
to have that technical support available
so i'm i'm just questioning whether this
is something that you would think about
changing if
you can be assured by the department
which i've always been assured that
somebody would be present to
provide that advice
um certainly i i would i just
my hesitation only is that
um instead of technical just technical
support um i would expect that this
person
would offer some suggestions from from
their standpoint how
uh things might be changed um like
application forms or something like that
that they would
they would even offer uh some
information at the at the um
meetings rather than just sit in the
back and when we call them up you know
say you know give us this technical
issue but how you know if it's
i'm not aware that it was wasn't
something that wasn't being done so if
it's there's some way to change this
uh i'm more than happy to do that
would
uh would you be opposed to this being
called a
uh oversight
advisory council
whereas then we could have for example
like
dave waters and i have both chaired at
times the advisory council for cte now
the the chair of that committee is jeff
beard who happens to be the
person from the d.o.e
uh so um i guess there's different ways
of looking at this yeah certainly
you know
it's in the semantics of it but um the
reason i called it a charter school
oversight committee was that it's in
statute now
and
in order to
if we had a council it would seem that
you would have then two bodies
doing the exact same thing that or close
close enough that it would be quite a
duplication kind of like a study of a
study
thank you
you have a question of reps and hobson
[Laughter]
okay are there any further questions
from the committee
yes representative moffitt thank you mr
thank you take my question i'm looking
at the existing statute and i see that
it calls for three senators and three
reps and would you believe i'm not
surprised that a meeting is not included
three senators
yes uh they've really had quite a
problem with that makeup yes they do so
further comments or questions from the
committee not saying thank you very much
thank you
um do we need more cards
i don't think we have any other cards on
this
on this bill so with that we're going to
close the hearing
and that takes us into the business
other business of today
which is to look at executing
and we can continue on the executing off
on the uh the four bills that we hadn't
yet do you need a caucus or anything
such as that
i do need a few minutes here to make
sure that we get all the committee
reports down to the few minutes let's
take a few minutes
yeah and so we need to get that to
lindsay she has to have all this stuff
out this morning
yeah i wanted to also confirm which ones
um
we're doing
are we also doing 1229
i have to look at it that's the uh
representative oregon's uh
you've um 12 29. all right
you
okay we're we're about ready to move
forward into doing something exactly on
these bills
i'd like to know the name of that cereal
you're getting over there in the morning
okay for the for for committee members
uh we have a list of bills which we want
to go over and so i'll share that with
you right now so you know where we're
going and um
and the need for perhaps a break or two
within that schedule for us either to
you know talk uh to the individual
caucuses for for about four or five
minutes or to maybe uh amendments but uh
that i think that'll be later so the
first bill which we'll be looking at and
then i'm going to go down the list is
1564.
that's a bill dealing with breakfast
a unique pupil identifier type
bill
and then uh 1639 we're going to do at a
later time there's probably amending
language which we brought forward we
don't have that together at this point
in time
we will be dealing with that that's not
on that initial list it's what we came
up with last night jointly to work
towards getting these accomplished
12-12 hb 12-12 we will be addressing
that
12 41
14 28
uh 1588
uh 1336 we'll probably add on to that
but we're gonna have to have a little
break before it uh to discuss that to be
about five
minutes uh then we have 12 36 which we
have some amending language that hasn't
been put together well it's been put
together but it's not over across the
street so we'll you know
we'll see
is that basically what you guys have on
the list both of you
yeah okay good so we're all on the same
page here
so let's start working now on the first
bill which is 15 64.
1564. if we can all turn to that
i'd like to have a dime every time i
turn these pages
1564 is the bill requiring school
districts provide breakfast for students
okay
going to the sheet here
do we have a motion from representative
hobson
yes we do mr chair um thank you very
much i am going to make a motion to itl
1564.
um much like other legislations we need
a second oh sorry
represent nelson is the second
okay
go ahead with the maker of the motion
sure so much like the bills some of the
other legislation that we've heard in
the past couple of weeks
for this breakfast program about 430
schools out of 466
are already providing these services to
students
and based on the
testimony or guidance i guess from the
doe
the federally
federal
government would not fund the startup
costs
and the continuing costs for positions
that would be needed to oversee
this program
so i'm hoping that our committee will
remember the other study committee that
we talked about yesterday and this is
one of the items that we can add to that
yeah
represent nelson did you have uh any
comments
from the committee any other comments
not yes representative ellison uh thank
you mr chair uh i'll just repeat what i
said yesterday that a priority for this
committee should be feeding students
whether it's breakfast or lunch
uh and i guess i would also add that
since i look at the list of sponsors and
our friends representative wolf and
representative allard our sponsors on
this that that tends to make me think
that it's a good piece of legislation
further discussion
representative
uh thank you um you know
breakfast is so important i mean it's
it's the
in many circles it's the most important
meal of the day
to get kids and for kids to get started
off on the right foot at school
and there are ways to get
breakfast i know with kearsarge we had
every student practically was bussed in
or drove in and
sometimes the buses were late and it it
was a problem with the breakfast program
but
what they did was they had bags
that kids that were coming in later
running late could just come to the
cafeteria and pick up a bag that had you
know a power bar in it and some other
things just to get some food in them and
um i know i worked with teenagers which
can be like locusts sometimes because
they're they're growing and uh you know
they grow an inch in a in a couple of
weeks and they just need so many
calories and so much food i'm i'm very
jealous of that but uh it was something
that um you know like i said yesterday i
kept food
in my area and i know almost every other
teacher
did that because you'd have kids that
you would see just you know
dr drowsy or just not acting and say you
know do you need something to kind of
pick yourself up and eventually they got
to the point where they knew where they
could go to get some food so i think
this is a really important
program um
and i just back up with representative
ellison said thank you thank you further
discussion representative woodcock and
then uh
represent lakes and then represent
london
thank you chairman good morning
i would like to follow up in the same
the same line we spoke about again
yesterday
on the breakfast meals i don't see this
as a study committee i don't see this
wrapping this is pretty this is pretty
clear feed the youngsters breakfast
there's they're already on the
nutritional program the school's off the
lunch it's the most important meal of
the day to start the day for for kids
when they get there um
it's it's almost inexcusable that we
have the opportunity to provide a meal
that we know
we know from all of our data all of our
research the brain easily you know get
going um and and this is it these kids
are growing and we're not doing
ourselves any academic success
why not giving this opportunity to start
today with something in their stomachs i
know very few of us around this table
would allow our children to start the
day when they were in school without
breakfast
why should we do the same thing with
those that can't afford it thank you
representative
which was
represented
as so often
i say it's a 28-day violation and if we
want to do yes there's some things but
the problem is their estimate
they said as much as 23 000 per school
in startup costs not covered
um
those who meet the requirements but
don't apply which there are quite a few
of where they will not be able to be
reimbursed for
etc so
that's why i see
this going i mean if town wants to do it
that's awesome if we can encourage towns
to do it that's awesome but forcing them
to do it without fully funding it
that's my problem and so that's why i
think it needs to be fixed
because we're forcing and we're
mandating schools to do it without fully
funding it and that's a 28a violation
and so that's why
before that committee that's what you've
got to look at how about those other
costs how about the 28 000 how about the
ongoing
you know pay for whoever puts those bags
together or whatever it is
somehow we have to cover if we're going
to mandate it we have to cover it
that's that's the constitution
thank you representative luno
thanks very much mr chair and um
and
so i'm sort of focused on a on a
different um
part in
in this bill
down on on line 10
it
it changes current law
from from allowing school districts to
decide whether or not they'll
participate in the national school
breakfast program to shall participate
in the national school breakfast program
i don't know what other implications
that may have like do you also have to
participate in the national school lunch
program because there are some districts
that don't participate in the national
school lunch program
and i don't recall from my time on the
board
what what what the pros and cons were
but i think there are reasonable pros
and cons
for determining whether or not a school
district participates in the usda
national school uh lunch program
uh i know we had that conversation in
hopkinton many years ago uh uh it may
have to do with uh with with the um uh
requirements on uh on on the news
nutritional requirements or the certain
food product requirements that uh
that um that that students um would be
receiving it may be that that districts
want to move
want to move a different way on it i i'm
i'm i apologize that that i'm not as
current on that argument but but i think
it's uh i think it's something that
would require
further um
analysis on on the part of of the
committee
and we did only hear i think from
representative duchess on um on this
bill so we don't i don't have any
additional background um on it
and i guess the final thought is with
102 bills i don't think we have time to
fix everything
and um there's going to be some things
that that may be maybe good bills but um
but we we
we just don't have the capacity
to address everything at this time so
i'm i'm
i'm going to support the motion of itl
were there any other representatives rep
santana
just as a little information i just
looked up um
how much is the average cost to produce
a breakfast for a school child and it's
2.72 cents
with a federal subsidy
of a dollar 88 taken away from that so
that's what we're talking about we're
not talking about 23
thank you
is there further discussion on this bill
then madam clerk would you please call
the roll
yes thank you this is bill 1564
requiring school districts to provide
breakfast to students the motion on the
table is itl
glenn cordelli
yes
rep litchfield is yes representative
boehm yes
representative lakis
yes representative moffat yes
representative hobson yes representative
ford
yes
representative saudi yes representative
nelson
representative luno yes representative
cornell
yes representative tiener
no
representative allison resounding no
representative
no
representative woodcock no
representative porter
representative hall
yes
okay and chairman ladd yes
okay the vote is 14 to 4 ito
so
do we have 18 here
yeah
okay
okay good so
um will there be a minority report
ellison okay okay
thompson
all right
okay moving on to
1626.
relative to the unique pupil
identification system
representative cordelli
thank you mr chair i would like to move
uh ought to pass on 1626.
is there a second
okay thank you so we have a motion made
by representative cordelli and second by
representative tanner
represent cordelli
thank you mr chairman
basically this was a result of
discussions with the department of
education
and
is
current practice
provided
by the department
and
it was felt that uh statutes uh should
be brought up to date with what is
actually going on
um as this information is required uh
in chartered public schools and by the
scholarship organization to do their
work
so
statutes should reflect uh
reality and what is required of these
organizations
represent tanner do you have further
yes i agree with uh representative
cordelli and
in that it's a a needed um tool
to gather data and also to make sure
that
um we're meeting this the appropriate
statutes um by having this information
thank you
thank you is there further discussion
not to see any hands thank you madam
clerk please call the rule
disregarding house bill 1626 relative to
the unique people identification system
the motion is ought to pass
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lacus yes
yes
represent hobson
yes representative ford
representative soti yes
representative nelson yes representative
luno
yes represent cornell yes
representative tanner yes represent
allison
represent mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative porter
representative hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
so ought to pass eighteen to zero
represent my uh daughter is an
audiologist and if you need some help
later on for being attested or assessed
uh on
i certainly appreciate your generosity
mr chair and to my colleague to the left
i would simply say if the shoe fits
you keep them in order please
is that consent okay on this one
any objections not seeing any thank you
so we'll place uh 1626 on the
consent agenda uh the next bill that we
have tentatively on that list and the
reason why we're not doing it today
that's uh uh 1672 misuse of efa funds we
have a number of bills left on efas and
they kind of all intertwin and twain
with each other and we're going to put
them all together so we can have that
discussion at a later date
okay so those bills are intertwined
there so we'll now go on to the uh next
bill which we have on the dock which is
this is relative to the rules of the
department of education concerning
culture and climate in schools
do we have a a motion for this
reps and cordelli
i will move itl
is there a second
represent cornell thank you
representative cordelli
thank you um
uh i understand the intent
and we are all concerned about uh the
culture and what's going on in our
schools um but
i don't think this
bill as uh drafted
um
provides uh
really the
information or the
scope of
what might be included i i think that
there's a lack of definition
and
other problems with the legislation as
drafted
and therefore i i don't think it should
go forward as is
representative do you have any further
comments
i i do have a comment on that in support
of what uh representative cordelli and
representative cornell have uh made with
their motions here
that if you look at the minimum
standards for public school approval
in 306
um
0.06 it mentions culture and climate i'm
looking at the categories listed
underneath it a and b and c
and that's stuff that we're all doing or
should be doing in our schools right now
uh i have no objections the way the the
department has set this up and it's been
approved by jalcar
which is our own legislative committee
and so with that i i also support uh the
motion that's on on the table before us
here
any further discussion yes represent
tanner um yes i i think it's important
to also realize that we've had
quite a
study in a governor's council
that has really reported on culture in
the school and made it made some very
strong recommendations
um
that in the in their 2018 report so i
think
uh that covers a lot of the issues that
that people were bringing up thank you
yeah and that was a commission study
which was widely participated in uh and
we've had you know perry plummer
involved with that which even was
homeland security and safety so
um a lot to it
so any further discussion from the
committee
not seeing any requesting for that so we
will go ahead with uh 1198 would you
please call the role madam clerk
yes this is house bill 1198 relative to
rules of the department of education
concerning culture and climate in
schools the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative lakas yes representative
moffitt yes representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes representative
cornell yes
representative tiener yes
representative ellison
represent mullen
yes
representative woodcock yes
representative porter
representative yes
yes
and chairman ladd yes
so itl 18 to 0.
any objections to consent
not seeing any thank you
okay the next bill which we have before
us is
12 12
relative to charges for charter public
school transportation
this bill clarified the charter public
school pupils are provided
transportation by the school district on
a on all full and half days it has
school
is there a motion
whoever yeah it's
open game
itl
so we have a motion on a table made by
cornell and second by lad
for itl
1212. uh represent cornell
yes
i spoke to the transportation person at
the manchester school district and they
assure me that they work very very hard
with all of the charter schools in
manchester to try to coordinate
calendars as soon as the calendar comes
out
and that they do provide transportation
on days that
the calendar is different manchester in
case anyone doesn't know also provides
transportation to all of the private
schools too in manchester not just the
public charter schools they provide to
holy family mount st mary's mount zion
saint benedict's and catherine st joseph
so
i think the public schools that go above
and beyond trying to coordinate and
provide transportation and
transportation if anyone's looked at
school budgets is a huge amount of money
so i think maybe in the future better
cooperation between
public schools and public charter
schools on calendars would be the right
way to go on this so i move itl
thank you very much representative bowm
thank you mr chair i totally agree with
representative cornell one of the
problems we've had saying with cte
i don't think it's a big issue for
charter schools which everybody knows
i'm pro-charter schools align the
calendars
and in manchester where you have four or
five charter schools and
i mean all over the place i mean yeah
it's it's kind of hard to do that in
impossible uh but yeah all the schools
have to do and charter schools should
hey align your calendars and you
everybody's still got to go 180 days so
make them the same and i don't see that
big of a deal especially if it's in
one school district we have a big no we
have a big issue with cte because
there's multiple school districts we're
talking one school district allowing
your calendar
thank you
when we're talking the cte program
remember that
if a student's
from their home to the school they get
themselves from the home to the school
and then the ascending school provides
that service down wherever your career
tech center is or it may be in fact in
the building then of course you wouldn't
even have it that day then but uh
yeah it's it's a requirement that and if
the kids don't use that they're given x
numbers pennies
per mile for a reimbursement
uh for their transportation if they
self-transport
so represent like us
i just wondered if as soon as this is
done i could inject an off topic that
had to do with the bill yesterday
i talked to the cte last night i went to
their open house
and they said thank you everybody i
wanted you to know they said thank you
for passing the bill yesterday making it
10 days they said it and i thought 10
days was an awful lot 46 this year
at alvirne cte which is regional cte 46
days difference in the calendar
so they said to tell all of you thank
you very much that was the nature and
reasoning for the for the bill and uh
they're working towards it they're
working towards it so let's get back to
uh
1212 here
so is there any further discussion on
1212 the motion was to high tl the bill
not seeing hands madam clerk
house bill 1212 relative to charges for
chartered public transportation motion
on the table is itl representative
cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes representative
lakes yes representative moffatt
yes representative hopson yes
representative excuse me ford yes
representative soti yes
representative nelson
representative luno yes
representative cornell yes
representative tiener
yes
representative ellison
representative mullen
yes
representative woodcock
is that porter
representative hall yes and chairman
ladd yes
the motion of ito carries 18-0
okay
uh we're gonna take about a five-minute
break right here right now five minutes
yeah consent for that last bill
okay
we're going to be going into caucus
right now
and it's going to be about 20 minute
caucus
10 minutes
yeah that's good
that's right go take their care of that
voice ears too get some hot coffee
no no coffee no
caffeine yeah
see
are we still live mr chairman during
this caucus
representative litchfield can you hear
me are we live i think we are
was it hot i just i thought it was warm
you
okay folks we're going ahead we have
three more bills which we're going to be
exacting
this morning
hb 1428
relative to the provision of special
education services by charter public
schools
represent boom is there a motion
represent hobson for a second so we have
a motion on a table to itl 1428 made by
boehm second by hobson represent boehm
do you care to um discuss yeah i mean
this is
be kind um
it can't be done i mean a two-week lapse
in your district i mean
even in the regular public school
district it might take more than two
weeks to find the right person for the
disability
and by allowing the charter school to
give it
to if you can't do it in two weeks we're
going to do it that's just totally
unreasonable
um so
that's why the itl it's
and you know if if your public school
which has the resources to find people
can't find people and and the charter
school might just find somebody you know
completely
out of district and
cost million dollars more so
it's unreasonable for it especially for
two weeks
thank you
reps and hops and do you have anything
to add nope i would agree with um what
representative baum
further discussion representative
cordelli
yes thank you if i could just mention i
think um it was in relation to this bill
the subject of
charter schools and lease came in uh to
play
and i checked with the national center
for special education in charter schools
and i think this was from 2017-18
there were 27 states
in which
the charter school was part of an
e-l-e-a
just wanted to mention that and i'd like
to just add that
there's an extreme shortage of special
education personnel in the state
especially those that are occupational
therapists physical therapists speech
pathologists
and if you're a district that has a
folks on board i can remember the school
i had i had two speech pathologists in
the school alone
and that was just an elementary school
so um but to find them today is very
difficult and i can remember an
experience i had with my own grandchild
up in woodsville
and we could not find a speech
pathologist there and the speech
pathologist eventually was a contracted
service out of concord
and and that took a lot longer than two
weeks for this youngster it took about
six weeks for everything to get in place
and the district was honestly trying as
best they could and i don't think if
there were a charter school up there
that um
they'd find anybody there either
it's these people are just very rare and
when you find one latch on and keep it
so any further discuss reference
woodcock
thank you thank you chairman
um i think the other part that i find uh
concerning about this besides is
representative bowman said the two weeks
is impossible in public school
i find that that it's it's unfortunate
that a particular school and the
district district is set aside as they
get all the special dispensation when it
comes to special needs of the higher
district if one school in the district
if we can't find that specialist that's
happening within the whole district and
not just the one public charter school
in our district and i find that
relatively discriminatory and unfair as
well
thank you
that's a ricochet effect
and it's it's very legitimate
uh
represent porter just just another aside
on the topic mr chair and committee
members
i was fortunate to be the chair of the
new hampshire commission on deafness and
hearing loss for a while and one of um
that's another area where there's a lot
of shortages of of people to deal with
children who have are deaf or hard of
hearing
and we actually asked to have put in the
budget funding for um
a loan forgiveness program for
people
who would take up this kind of
profession in new hampshire
and one of the issues that we have with
these people these kinds of professions
here is that our pay scale is low
so the a lot of the people that would
come here are going to other states
around because they get more money for
doing that service so it's they don't
all interact all intertwined
represent nelson did you have your hand
up
yeah somebody ended up asking this and
if it was a contracted service that had
a mileage paid by mileage they could
bring somebody in from berlin down to
salem and you'd really be up to crete
and just to take on to that if you get a
contract or service out of concord up
where you pay the transportation school
district years ago they used to pay for
that transportation
that's been cut out
it's no longer there for school
districts so
there's a lot to this that we we should
be aware of
further discussion
madam clerk
thank you this is house bill 1428
relative to the provision of special
education services by chartered public
schools the motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes
representative blakis yes
represent moffitt yes
represent hobson yes president ford yes
representative
yes represent nelson
representative luno yes
representative cornell
yes
representative tanner yes
or sam ellison yes
where's that mullen yes
from sam woodcock
represent porter yes
representative hall yes and chairman
ladd yes okay itl 18-0
consent any objections great thank you
okay what's the next one on the docket
um
1588.
1588 relative to students attending
public schools that mandate the wearing
of a face mask
without an emergency order in place
i'll make the motion
all right
call on uh chairman ladd for a motion
i'll make a motion to itl on the bill
second second
representative moffat seconds
would there be any discussion from the
maker of the motion
no
from the second of the motion
any further discussion amongst the
committee
i guess uh we're ready for a vote
talk okay i'll talk more slowly
while the um
more slowly but not more loudly
while the clerk prepares the uh the
sheets necessary for doing her job which
she has been doing so effectively uh
representative hopson
just to belabor the point i was just
wondering what are you gonna have for
lunch today uh rob cordelli
mr chair yes i i'd like to second what
you just said that um that
representative litchfield has been doing
an outstanding job
and i think the way she's announcing
the the bill and calling for the vote
has just been been tremendous and the
and the growth
in this um in this capacity is just um
so um i just want to
put that on the table well does anybody
else have anything else to add
i agree with representative luno the
elocution has been marvelous from that
she was a high draft choice
the only the only problem with
her
job function right now is parking but
that's another issue
like parking your car here around the
building
house bill 1588 relative to students
attending public schools that mandate
the wearing a face mask without an
emergency order in place the motion on
the table is itl
representative cordelli
yes
okay representative litchfield is a nay
representative
yes
representative lakis no
representative moffett
no
representative hopson
yes
okay um representative
no
representative nelson
yes representative luno yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison
representative mullen yes representative
woodcock yeah president porter yes we
have
yes
for sure i'm sorry point of order
i misspoke on my vote on on this
particular measure
yeah you seconded it yes i did
yes i did and i
misspoke that's the first time i've ever
done that and i would ask if i could
if i could
change my vote yes you may do so you're
now jacked down to major rather than
lieutenant colonel uh
madam clerk i would
like to be a yes on that one thank you
the gavel has not come down that's
legit
okay
so the motion is at oh oh yeah
i'm a yes
so the motion ito carries 15 to 3.
so that will go on consent is there any
objection
we've had 15 or 3 go on consent before
that's about as much of a difference
that you can have
okay so that's on consent
um we will go to the next bill which is
1336.
by the way does anybody know what
happened in 1588 that's the last bill we
did
the spanish armada
went down
remember that
sir francis drake
i was there yeah
yeah yeah
when i was a boy growing up in canada
they taught us english history uk and
that was ingrained in our minds that
armada
1066 and all that mr chair yes you bet
1336 now and i can't tell you what
happened that year
the black beth
okay 1336 is relative to rulemaking by
the state board of education concerning
violations of the professional code of
ethics and the professional code of
conduct
is there a
yeah motion
would like to like us yeah i would like
to make a motion that this goes the same
way as the black death and we get rid of
it
um
and i'll i'll second that okay in here
any second
itl
black death that's the motion the black
death now
ready for me to speak miss yes go ahead
okay
um
we've been in communication with the doe
and they have asked us not to put this
in law because it makes it harder for
changes to be made and there are some
changes that they're working on right
now
and if we
codify this then it will you know be
that much longer before they can make
the changes so
that's why thank you
okay and i i made the second and i'd
like to go into this a little bit
um
there are several issues with the bill
beside
what is
it was the way it was written i
initially put this together and
represented leicester took it
um addresses both the code of ethics and
the code of conduct the code of ethics
is aspirational
and it's not the conduct it's not what
you're doing it's not the action
and this bill if we were to
act on it
we'd have to re-change that title of the
bill so it's not code ethics it's the
code of conduct which we're addressing
but more importantly to me
i i think there's another process in
which
we can address some of the issues
dealing with this rather than having to
place
certain aspects of the code into
statutory language
and right now the department does have
the authority to
deal with this topic by way of what
we've done previously in years past
i'm
proposing that we also as a committee
forward a letter to the
department of education
which uh i've addressed that issue with
the attorney from the department and i'd
like to take a moment and read that
letter
and and if we're
all good with that then we would you
know you know sort of tie that in with
this you know what we're going to do
here is that we itl and ford are our
concern to the department
it goes on dear commissioner edelbloom
following the submission and hearing of
hv 1336 regarding the new hampshire code
of ethics and the code of conduct for
educational professionals
i've been asked on behalf of the
education committee to forward an
additional option that may assist the
department and state board when dealing
with matters of professional educator
conduct
hb 1336 incorrectly referenced both the
code of ethics and the code of conduct
the committee recognizes that the code
of ethics is aspirational and meaning
while the code of conduct is directly
associated with professional educator
action
the intent of hb 1336 was strictly
designed to address the code of conduct
and to codify the terms of riverman
suspension and revocation in statute it
has been determined that by addressing
like terminology directly in statute
rather than making any modifications to
quote of conduct through the rule-making
process would be in error
therefore rather than amending the code
of conduct through legislation the
committee
opines
some of that legal talk and our lawyer's
not here
that modification to the code can best
be accomplished through the rule-making
process
in addition to the three categories of
action that may be administered for
infractions of the code of conduct
the education committee requests that
the new hampshire board of education
consider an option prior to
administering reprimand suspension or
revocation as an outcome
in re-lettering the three options
previously noted
the one two and three i just mentioned
the committee recommends that rule
making process include a fourth category
that would precede reprimand suspension
or revocation the first option would
then state
a confidential letter of concern which
shall mean a non-disciplinary non-public
letter issued to the employee
or and then it's or and then we go up
into the and then followed by reprimand
suspension and revocation is currently
in the code of conduct thank you for
considering the committee's request and
please do not hesitate to call me
contact me if further information is
necessary that's the letter which we i'd
ask for support from the committee to
forward if we go through with the itl uh
as as proposed
any objections to that
okay so any further discussion on this
bill represent luna do you have anything
no but uh but thank you very much um mr
chair and and uh certainly appreciate
the committee's um
um uh i think um you know wise um um uh
move in this uh in this direction so and
i want to thank um well
i want to thank um attorney fenton for
uh
helping advise in that
in that capacity as well yep that was a
learning experience for me
every time we talk with attorney fentany
it's a learning experience
and her reward i provided her one of her
yellow books
yeah
okay so is there further discussion from
the committee here
not seeing any madam clerk would you
please call the roll
thank you this is house bill 1336
relative to rulemaking by the state
board of education concerning violations
of the professional code of ethics and
the professional code of conduct the
motion on the table is itl
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm yes representative
lakis yes
moffitt yes represent hobson yes
representative ford yes
yes representative nelson yes
representative luno yes represent
cornell yes from sam tanner yes
representative ellison yes represent
mullen yes represent woodcock
representative porter yes representative
hall yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay
18 to 0.
okay so we will forward that letter off
too and um
this takes us to the bottom of the list
which
yes is there any objection to consent
no okay so it's 18
00 consent
okay
we had 12 36 but i don't think that
amendment is ready
that deals with the legislative
oversight committee for improvement and
assessment
i think that would once we get that
designed i think that shouldn't be a
problem
is there anything else that we want do
we want to discuss the efas today and
try to
what we're looking at what i'm looking
at is we have a number of bills dealing
with efa i'd like to
do them all at one time we have some
duplication we have some duplication
also on the mass
and to
bring those together there's no sense
acting separately on three or four bills
when in fact
we can probably
meld
into one bill
or or or
take advantage of the
time that limited time we have and
discuss them all at once rather than
going through the same repetitive
discussion over and over and over
so i and and uh and so in addition to
the efas and those those you know
intertangled related
bills and the three i think we're
looking at are 1355
1672 and 1669. yes
i think we have similar uh interrelated
bills where where it um where they apply
to co-op school districts yes and then
masks
and um and maybe what uh maybe what we
could do is um is go through our
remaining bills and try to i mean like
we can work together on on
yeah
we'd spoken last night i believe in
about the cooperative schools districts
uh
that you know is no sense doing those as
individual on different days
let's get let's hit it and and you know
if you want to nuke the whole program
like the person sitting beside me that's
fine but uh let's talk about that all at
one time
and i and i really like um mr i really
like the approach that you're you're
taking where we can discuss all three
and then exec them separately following
discussion yes and there may be an
amendment prepared between discussion
and exec yeah
it will certainly be a time saver if
there's four bills and we can figure
well here's the three we're going to get
rid of and we're going to go you know
and we'll have to come to agreement
and we're never all going to agree
as we i think we've even seen a little
bit today on certain topics it's it's
it's just just the way it is in america
so
yeah and and you know from from today as
well rick
um i like the fact that we got we got
some split votes on on both sides
because i think that that shows that uh
you know we're all um you know bringing
our own sort of experience and
representing our constituents um well so
so i'd like to um you know
extend my thanks to uh to you know both
ends of the room here in uh in doing
that
so
my parting words would be that now that
we will try to get a flow chart out to
you with all the updated information
what we have done or haven't done
and we know that we have x number of
days left approximately seven days
excluding that week of the 28th which we
want to take off
so there's going to be four days that
following week and we have about you
know well we know we have the
well i think the 15th take we have some
bills that we're doing on hearing there
we took from the fourth
and looking at this schedule what we
have left there we may have about six
days left which are available for
exactly i think we can do it
and we should be able to do it
if we just you know
all don't try to say something over and
over and over again or
i'm not looking at you represent the
woodcock
i'm looking at rips and like us over
here
well i can always hear him so you don't
ever have to worry about that
so
but you know look these bills over
because we're going to come down to the
point where we're going to have to delve
into everything
and it shouldn't come as a great shock
that we're doing it
we're going to have to do it and so the
time is limited
so be looking at the efa bills to be
looking at the co-op bills be looking at
the masking bills
there's some other bills but those are
ones which i will communicate with
represent lunon will try to work out but
those other bills
advise right now
look at them because we could be taking
them up pretty much so
can i are you okay with me asking you a
question about this chairman yeah
so the masking bills yesterday we talked
a little bit about whether or not the
25th was going to be a date that we used
to
hear
whatever the numbers yes we had two
bills just recall that we had postponed
right seating right so would we be doing
all of the masking bills on that day
how would we
i is that the 25th or the 15th
no it's the 25th it's the 25th it's
friday the 25th that's the day that the
fourth bills were taken
yeah yeah
so
if there's time
we can't be messing around a whole lot
so we may take some of the other efa
bills of the mass bills up on that on
that date we're on that topic
right yeah i just want to be prepared
yeah yeah be prepared okay all right i'm
saying be prepared on the masking on the
efas and the co-op districts yep uh
bills those are bills which you know if
we get some moments of course we're
going to need more time to discuss all
those bills at one time but if we have a
day dedicated to that like we do on the
25th
that would be a good day to take up the
other masking stuff
yeah represent woodcock
thank you chairmanlet i appreciate the
the uh
early information so we can prepare uh
your
position that you're going to speak with
representative luno so he can get to us
in terms of the agenda for
uh
the upcoming days
yeah i'm going to still work with as we
have been doing okay fine thank you but
you know a lot of that has been filtered
out yet okay so thank you thank you for
which we do things thank you
coming up for next week
yeah
that's exactly right on
yes that that's the 15th and then the
16th a half day and the 17th is a full
day in manchester
the following week is the week and where
we can
address some see that will be the week
of the
21st that's the week in which we're
going to have to hammer out a lot of
these bills we will also have the week
after that
the second week in
march
where we come back from
winter spring break whatever it might be
uh to to deal with some bills right
there there we have to have them out of
this committee
by the 10th i believe it is
so will
there's none scheduled this monday
none
yeah i was going to talk to
representative ford here we haven't had
that opportunity here in the last
several days
so um that that will be pushed off i'm
also waiting to get some feedback back
from the community college system from
shannon reed
who's been working with mark rubinstein
and with tom cronin at the university
system of new hampshire they're looking
at a possible proposal on top of the
tennessee proposal that we've talked
about
tennessee has this in statute
yeah
anything else today
we are done enjoy the day it's warmer
outside mr mr chair the uh the black
death was 1346 not 1336 they just
changed
it up yes i did
did they wear masks
i'm not sure about the mask use but it
lasted for several years and
it killed about a third of the people in
europe yeah and it came back again and
again too
different iteration
he used diver mekton
yeah that's the thing
just a quick note on the 25th when we
are in repsol we'll do the hearings over
there
but then we will come back to this room
on the 25th to do our exacting
work so so it's very difficult to do
exact work in that hall it's just it's
not a good forum
and
i don't get
it's um
what's the matter
you
this room and how she puts it in the
calendar that we're going to be
executing over here so she'll take
she'll work that out yeah yeah
she can just take one of those bills
yeah she can work that out yeah yeah
i'll let her know about that's right i
don't want to get her all right
check and see which um is down
discrimination
uh
i mean
you
no testing
are we still live on
youtube probably not
you